you know colton underwood shot to
reality show fame as the first virgin
bachelor
that was the big sell that season yeah
definitely was but now we know there was
so much more going on inside of colton
because today
he revealed his truth about his
sexuality
i've ran for myself for a long time i've
hated myself for a long time and
i'm gay i am a virgin
really the truth is i was a virgin
bachelor because i was gay
and i didn't know how to handle it did
you ever think about harming yourself
yeah even just suicidal thoughts and
you know driving my car close to a cliff
like oh if this goes off the cliff it's
not that big of a deal
the former nfl player told gma he came
to terms with his sexuality earlier this
year
the 29 year old talked to us last year
about struggling with rumors in high
school
even googling am i gay what conclusions
did you ultimately draw
about yourself well i could say this i
never acted on anything
there was a rumor going around my high
school that i was gay because i broke up
with
one of my girlfriends at the time and it
even got to my mom
where my mom was was you know pulled me
aside and said you know i'd like he'd
still love you if you were gay
so what did the shows teach you about
your sexuality
i mean obviously then i'm straight and
that i'm very very attracted to cassie
and
and women fence jumping colton also
apologized to his ex cassie randolph
he stayed with her parents while
recovering from covid last year
and then things turned ugly she filed
and later dropped a temporary
restraining order against him
i just wish i wouldn't have dragged
people into my own mess of figuring out
who i was
so what's next well the reality star is
reportedly working on a netflix series
about his coming out journey
with a man i've never allowed myself to
and i'm looking for someone who can push
me and challenge me in all the great
ways
you